zach frankie on the mound today against
the texas rangers
you can take a look at his fit numbers
his expected era
fielding independent pitching entails
everything that does not
involve anybody else's control but zach
so that's home runs walks and strikeouts
so back-to-back hits start off the game
for the rangers with conor felefer and
ebonyes and they have two men on with
nobody out
a little tapper towards first toro who's
playing first base today
giving uli guriel the day off steps on
the bag as low as retired
moving runners to second and third
here's joey gallo you can see he has
never had a career hit against zach
grinky
got him big strikeout for grenkey second
and third one out
gallow goes down on strikes against zach
and a big second out for the astro
starter
finding that spot up top to beat joey
gallo
seen joey gallow over the years have
trouble up in the zone but zach
exploited that
beautifully in that at-bat now i have to
get jonah high
ground ball right side jose altuve will
have it and make the play
in time to get high grenkey gets through
a second and third
one out situation to shut down the
rangers in the first the rangers had a
chance in that first inning to take
their
first lead in over two weeks the rangers
won't lead after this inning so they are
tied with the braves
with no leads over 96 innings they are
approaching a modern day
record taylor hearn 30 games on the
season just one start so this will be
his second start
of the season two and three record 4.7
era for taylor he's got 50 strikeouts
he's done a nice job with the swings and
misses this year those 50 strikeouts
have come
in 46 innings a big payoff to altuve
and he sends this one in the air out to
right field that'll hang up a little bit
for gallo who had to
cover some ground to get in and make
that play that just did not carry
one away you're on alvarez now battling
him well though the one-two pitch and
there's a little roller could be two
holt the second one kind of falloffa
onto first easily in time to get alvarez
the rangers get the double play
five six three and for the first time in
his career
taylor hearn has pitched a scoreless
full first inning in a baseball game
here's curtis terry terry the designated
hitter today oh for eight in his first
two games as a major leaguer
swing and a miss zach grenky gets a
strikeout of curtis terry that is the
second strikeout for zach went away in
the inning
here's brock holt left-handed hitting
third baseman batting 205.
a little tapper to altuve he'll flip to
correa no chance for a double play but
they get the lead runner david dahl on a
fielder's choice for the second house
here's connor falefa single this first
time
fly ball center field chaz mccormick
back has a beat on it and he puts it
away for the final out of the inning
frankie's worked around a little traffic
we're still scoreless the rangers have
set a modern day record most consecutive
innings without a lead that's a tough
pill to swallow right there
that's almost 11 games consecutively
yeah they're almost there
abraham toro leads it off here against
taylor hearn
toro strikes out looking one away a good
slider here from
taylor hearn the last two strikeouts the
only two of the game have to be
on sliders one of them was an up and in
slider to mccormick and this is a
backdoor slider
perfectly done just a little bit of cut
to it and catching that down and away
corner from taylor hearn
martine maldonado two and two and a
strikeout swinging maldonado is the
third straight strikeout victim for
hearn
so taylor kind of settling in a little
bit getting stronger as this one wears
on yeah and i would say
even exceeding expectations right now
pitch number 38 of the afternoon is
another slider
and a very good one all right robel
garcia switch hitting third baseman
slow roller right side of the infield
and a nice play by
they get garcia the inning is done and a
hat tip to taylor hearn three scoreless
innings in his start this afternoon all
right so now the fifth inning brock holt
will lead it off
and he gets a call again sneaks that one
in the back door
and strikes out holt for the first time
in the inning and holt
not having it he's not and he shouldn't
know brock holt tossed out of this game
but remember yesterday too he had a call
go against him
that was pretty unfair so eventually
you're going to pop
oh boy well you'd understand the
frustration's a little high
for all those guys in rangers blue on
top of it timmins has been frustrating
today
he has and it's been both sides of the
play you cannot open up both sides of
the play we talk about the idea of
getting a couple of inches
here and there but brock holt had a
really good argument
and good for woody for being out there
as well holt had had enough
and woody had already had enough hulk
getting tossed gave woody a reason to
come out
woody's second ejection of the year
after tim timmons gave him the heave ho
holt got into tim timmon's face
and that's when chris woodward came out
and also got tossed
so one out and no one on for eli white
and it's two balls and no strikes
this ball hit hard by eli white and it
is gone
into the crawford boxes over the 19-foot
high wall perhaps the rangers have been
electrified by the ejections
it's one nothing rangers the first lead
in 99 innings this would have been their
100th inning without a lead before the
eli white home run
now abraham toro who was a switch hitter
so he's gone in this game from being a
right-hand hitter to a left-handed
hitter mid-game there goes mccormick
again this ball drilled deep to right
field
abraham toro two-run home run
astros takes the lead 2-1 with a two-run
shot in the fifth torres showing some
quick hands on that 2-2
astros finally getting that big swing
and regaining that lead
and abraham toro smashed it
[Applause]
107-107.3 back-to-back
walks issue joely will face the
left-hand hitting kyle tucker the
one-two
that ball hit hard and passed the diving
second baseman of bonies
jordan alvarez being waved home gallows
throw
not in time astros lead 3-1 rbi
signal by kyle tucker one of the best
arms in the outfield but jordan got a
good jump and the big man
picked him up and put him down to score
the run
to give the astros a two-run lead
christian javier comes in with the bases
loaded nobody out
and this will be his 20-second
appearance it'll be his
13th out of the bullpen for the astros
made nine stars to begin the year he's
three in one with a 2.89
era infield back with nobody out in the
bases full
there's a swing and a miss got him with
a 95 mile an hour fastball javier comes
in and picks up a big strikeout with a
base unloaded
no doubt about that one 95 right through
the heart of the zone
beating eli white so now he'll face
isiah connor falefa
line drive on the ground they go to
second for one double play
christian javier who rarely shows a
motion with a big fist pump
at the end of that double play ball was
hit hard but it was hit right at rebel
garcia who did a great job of catching
this ball on a short hop and then
feeding it to altuve for the big double
play
two out here's curtis terry last chance
for the rangers
got him foul tip caught by maldonado the
astros sweep the texas rangers
winning today three to one and for the
first time all year the astros moved to
22 games over 500 they hit the 100 game
plateau blummer at
61 and 39 in a great weekend series
against their
prostate rivals